[Music]
every tragedy has six parts plot
character diction thought spectacle and
song of these elements plot is the most
important for tragedies and imitation
not of men but of an action and of life
and the life consists in action and its
end is a mode of action not equality
seven years ago when I was still trying
to become a novelist I took a Master
Class by Aaron Sorkin on writing before
taking the class I self-published a
collection of essays many of which ended
up becoming my initial YouTube videos as
well as a short novel but everything I
had ever written was very small in scale
one day however I had an idea for what I
thought might be a grander more
compelling story but I didn't want the
idea to go to waste I didn't want to
write myself into a corner as I had done
so many times in the past hence the
master class and one of the things that
Aaron Sorkin stresses in this class is
the importance of reading this
Aristotle's Poetics I had never read
this book as I majored in Japanese at
University and I wasn't a drama kid in
high school not a good excuse I know so
I added this to my to read list and kept
going through the class jotting down
notes and ideas for my story along the
way but then life happened my wife got
pregnant now this is when I was still
working at Apu making about two thousand
dollars a month doing student
recruitment but also around the time
that my YouTube channel which I had
recently started as both a creative
Outlet and also a potential source of
future income
finally started to pick up some traction
as someone had shared one of my videos
on the learn Japanese Reddit and it was
there that several people encouraged me
to create a patreon which I did I put my
writing aspirations to the side and I
created a series on Japanese pitch
accent something I actually did study at
University I was feeling a lot of
pressure to provide of course because my
wife was pregnant but on top of that the
hotel that she had been working at for
the previous three years hotel in the
next town over had just been destroyed
in this cataclysmic earthquake and the
next month brought even more changes I
got my first check from patreon that was
awesome but then I also learned that my
wife was pregnant with not one but two
kids twin daughters I knew that my Apu
salary would never pay the bills for a
four-person family but also started to
see the potential of YouTube and patreon
both platforms where I was becoming
proud of what I was creating so I put
this and my storytelling aspirations to
the side and leaned into the so-called
YouTube grind and it paid off by the
time that my kids were born several
months later my combined YouTube and pay
patreon income was larger than my Apu
salary giving us just a little bit of
savings and hope for the future so I
quit Apu and leaned into YouTube and
fatherhood I scripted and shot my
YouTube videos for multiple years in
between diaper changes while my kids
were taking a nap or watching the
occasional movie and it was hard but it
was also very rewarding I felt like I
was being a pretty good dad and though I
wasn't making my creative writing
telling novels and I still hadn't read
this I was making my living through a
different form of creative writing
telling jokes about life in Japan and
learning the Japanese language and this
is the groove that I settled into my
YouTube sub count continued to grow but
my storytelling aspirations slowly faded
away
but one day all of that changed
[Music]
Edge Runners hit me like a ton of bricks
it was the wake-up call I needed it
reminded me of how powerful how
Transcendent good storytelling can be I
still cannot get through the I really
want to stay at your house music video
without crying I completely reassessed
my life I thought what are my goals and
what do I need to do in order to achieve
them I love making videos about life in
Japan and the Japanese language and it's
something I'm going to continue to do
indefinitely but watching Edge Runners
made it impossible for me to not at
least try to also engage in creative
writing in in storytelling so I picked
up where I left off I started waking up
early each morning to do things related
specifically to storytelling and that
form of creative writing and the first
thing that I did was I went through
Aaron sorkin's class one more time from
there I did James Cameron and David
mammoths and The Duffer Brothers I
finally got around to reading this as
well as a few other books but more
importantly after more than half a
decade I was finally writing again and
in the midst of all of this after a
series of unbelievable coincidences I
actually met the creator of edge Runners
rafaliyaki and ended up spending a day
with him and interviewing him here on
this channel all of this leads me to
known him I'm still a ways out from
being able to talk about either of the
two original stories that I'm trying to
create but recently I had the honor of
being able to work on a different
writing project and that's no name
rafal's new original Ip it's written by
him and illustrated by the brilliant
machine gallman so I served as one of
several editors on no name and now that
it's out I wanted to First encourage
people to go check it out to go read it
but also take this opportunity to talk
about what it was like to work behind
the scenes on an original manga how is a
manga made where do you even start well
Rafal like most started with a premise a
single sentence that describes the idea
what if people had powers based on the
meaning of their names and from there he
went into a little bit more detail about
the world no name is a dark action
mystery set in northern Europe where
Supernatural powers are attributed
through a person's name given to
everyone by the government a man
fighting with wolf Companions and a
Werebear girl investigate a missing
child case for the government-run naming
agency next was the outline a nine page
Google doc which very concisely
described the setting and its rules one
page
Story another page and the main
characters accompanied by concept art
about half a page for the written
descriptions with multiple pages of
concept art by Common now I asked a ton
of questions as this was an opportunity
for me to try and test some of the
knowledge I had acquired through my
research for example or fall this is
your first original Ip which of the four
quadrants do you plan on marketing this
to the most I can clearly see the
protagonists want in this outline but
can you tell me a little bit more about
their need after a fall answered my
questions he then asked me as well as
several of his much more qualified
friends for feedback he said what do you
think of the setting the story the
characters try and be specific I didn't
know if I could give informed feedback
but Rafal seemed to think that I could
maybe it was the Japanese Banks videos
joking aside I can understand why he
asked based on his previous work in
writer's rooms it's very difficult to
understand and wrap your head around the
things that you might be overlook
looking in your own work and bringing in
a set of external eyes even amateur eyes
can help you to immediately pinpoint
these kind of mistakes the things that
would have taken you weeks if not months
to notice by yourself and this is true
for many fields you don't need to be a
great cook in order to appreciate great
food and you don't need to be able to
dunk in order to tell which of two
basketball players is better at
dribbling that said I didn't really give
too much feedback on the outline in my
immediate first impression was oh yeah
this is the person that made Edge
Runners
I did find it very reassuring however
that Rafal had done exactly what all
these books were recommending which is
to finish the story at multiple
resolutions before you write a single
line of dialogue what I mean by this is
that he had the log line so the single
sentence that hooks readers in and then
he had a single paragraph that describes
its setting then on top of this he had
the actual story synopsis again the
story has been finished at multiple
levels the sentence level the paragraph
level and then the single page level you
want to do this you want to avoid
writing any dialogue before you know
exactly where the story is going because
of course if you don't you'll end up
writing a bunch of great dialogue and
cool scenes that actually aren't
necessary to the story and then you'll
be a little bit too proud to throw them
away as I've done multiple times in the
past and there Rafal sent over the first
script a different 36-page Google doc
that fleshed out the story with specific
locations actions and dialogue much like
a movie screenplay though it also had
some additional concept art from Goblin
mixed in once again Rafal asked me for
feedback and I gave it a read and this
time I actually thought that there were
a few things I might be able to comment
on namely the dialogue now I'm not great
at dialogue by any means but I've been
trying to do it on YouTube for long
enough to have developed at least a
specific style
and in that sense I was able to at least
leverage something during this part of
the editing process I would go through
the lines that Rafal had written and say
you know this is great I might have
written it this way what do you think
and one of the first drafts for example
I noticed that name powers and name game
Power abusers were being referred to as
just that within the dialogue itself and
I thought that there might be an
opportunity there to introduce Universe
specific slang for each one a bit like
you know the terms Chrome and cyber
psycho from Edge Runners I thought that
expanding the universe's lexicon so to
speak would cut down on redundancy but
also flesh out things a little bit Rafal
thought it was a good suggestion and
subsequently altered a few lines in the
script there were a few other bits like
this such as you know this line is great
but it might be even more powerful if
you pushed it back a little bit in this
line this character talks about their
wife and son in that order but then
later on they flip it is this
intentional I think I personally had the
most fun at this particular stage in the
project I mean talking about word order
and word choice I never really talk
about it publicly but I love this stuff
every tweet I've ever written I edited
and I revised for three or four hours
beforehand even if it's one sentence
long and at the same time that I and the
other editors were talking to her phone
gamma was using the script to create the
layouts the purpose of the layout is to
get a sense of how the visual story
flows how many panels are there going to
be generally speaking what are we going
to see from that point a few iterations
are made and the sketches are drawn
these come together a bit like a
storyboard showing the actual poses and
panels facial expressions Etc after that
comes the line art so the nearly
finished characters and backgrounds the
last step is to add the final dialogue
which Rafal had been revising this whole
time as well as the VFX and just like
that a new story is born it was
incredibly fun for me to work on no name
of course it was amazing to actually do
some work with Rafal but I mean I just I
learned so many things along the way
each editor picked up on completely
different things and then to watch
gamasan take this giant block of text
and turn it into this striking visual
story that was also incredible and on
top of the creative process Rafal also
shared the business side of things so
the costs the contracts the marketing
strategies Etc this was super valuable
to me because I have no business Acumen
but it also reinforced something that
I've heard all of my favorite creators
including Rafal say in the past and this
was
you can have the coolest idea I mean the
slickest characters in the wittiest
dialogue but nobody will ever know
unless you're actually able to bring it
to Market
got to put in the time and effort you
gotta wake up early and you gotta write
all right guys that's it go check out no
name I think what Rafal and gamasan have
created together is nothing short of
spectacular and I'm truly honored to
have had even a small role on the
project you can read it for free on the
shoe a shot Manga Plus platform linked
below where it's just past a million
views okay new comedic video coming soon
[Music]
thank you